my approach to self-development is very  specific and it has always been  predicated upon my desire to achieve  self-ownership while I constantly fight  to disengage from my ego however this  ardues task is so complicated that  oftentimes I have to face internal  conflict and even cognitive dissonance  striking a balance between so  challenging Endeavors can eventually  lead to a lack of motivation and even  desire to keep being part of this  Paradigm a potential remedy to that is  to adopt a more stoic stance some things  are within your control and some things  are beyond your control capitalize on  the former and laugh at the latter the  Quest for meaning has led many people to  insanity and especially if you have an  over analytical brain you can fall  easily into the Trap of obsession don't  let the absurdity of this world consume  you smile laugh at it be strong and  enjoy every aspect of the ride